مخاوف جديدة بشأن مصير ثلاثة
أمريكيين محتجزين في
نجمة كرة السلة الروسية بريتاني جرينر التي نعلم
الآن أنها محتجزة لمدة ثلاثة
أسابيع منذ 17 فبراير وفقًا
لعضو الكونجرس في مسقط رأسها كولين
أنه لم يكن لديها إمكانية الوصول إلى أي شخص من
حكومة الولايات المتحدة كما يقول وهي  ليس من
الواضح حتى مكان احتجاز الطحينة ،
يجب السماح لها بالعودة إلى المنزل في أقرب
وقت ممكن وعدم الانجراف في
أي من هذا السياق الأكبر الذي
يحدث ، تم إلقاء القبض على طحينة في
مطار موسكو مع ما
قالت السلطات الروسية إنه زيت الحشيش في
أمتعتها  يتهمون غرينر بتهريب
المخدرات التي يعاقب عليها بالسجن لمدة تصل إلى 10 سنوات ، ويشعر
أعضاء الكونغرس
والدبلوماسيون المخضرمون بالقلق من أن حصولها على
الميدالية الذهبية مرتين في الألعاب الأولمبية
باعتبارها نجمة رياضية قد تعمل ضدها كما
يمكن أن يكون توجهها الجنسي
مثلي الجنس ومتزوج من روسيا.  لديها قوانين صارمة للغاية بشأن
المثليين ، ما أتوقع
أن يفعله الروس
هو استخدام حقيقة أن زوجته
تعلن  تم
الإبلاغ عن هذه التصريحات في وسائل الإعلام ووسائل التواصل الاجتماعي على أنها
دعاية
لحقوق المثليين والمثليات والمثليين ومزدوجي الميل الجنسي ومغايري الهوية الجنسانية ، والتي يمكن أن تكون بعد
ذلك جريمة أخرى يمكن أن يتعرضوا
لها ضدها.
اتصل
به يوم الخميس يقول والدا ريد إن
حالته الجسدية قد أخذت منعطفًا
إلى الأسوأ حيث كان بالفعل
يسعل باستمرار ، وقال إنه
يسعل دمًا طوال اليوم
وأنه يعاني من الحمى وتزيد عن 100
درجة وأنه يعاني من
ألم في  الصدر
فقط جميع علامات مرض السل في
بيان جديد يقول والدا ريد إنه
قيل له إنه سيتم إرساله إلى مستشفى السجن
ولكن عندما كانا على الهاتف معه
يوم الخميس ، تم استدعاؤه إلى
لجنة تأديبية واقتبس أقوال
نخشى أن السلطات ربما  أعيدوه إلى
الحبس الانفرادي بدلاً من ذلك
، أدين ريد وزميله السابق في البحرية الأمريكية بول
ويلان بشكل منفصل
بجرائمهما التي ارتكباها.  نفي بشكل قاطع
واحتُجزوا في روسيا منذ
فترة طويلة قبل غزو أوكرانيا
، أعطت شقيقة ويلاند سي إن إن فكرة جديدة
عن حالته التي يقوم بها بشكل جيد
كما هو متوقع في معسكر العمل القسري
في وسط روسيا ، يشعر الخبراء الآن
بالقلق علانية  حول مستقبل
هؤلاء الأمريكيين الثلاثة بالنظر إلى أن
التوترات مع فلاديمير بوتين بشأن
الصراع في أوكرانيا تزيد فقط من
صعوبة إخراجهم
في هذه المرحلة ، فهل من الممكن ، نعم ،
نحن في مثل هذا المستوى المختلف  من
المواجهة مع روسيا في الوقت الحالي
، يتم استخدامهم بالفعل كرهائن من قبل
روسيا ، ولن يؤذي هؤلاء
الثلاثة ، لكنه لن يسمح له بالخروج
من السجن ، سواء قال
عضو الكونجرس كولين ألريد إن بريتاني
جرينر كانت على اتصال
بمحاميها الروسي وهذا  المحامية كانت
على اتصال
بوكيلها وعائلتها في الوطن وهم يعلمون أنها بخير.
حول حالتها وحالتها لم
نسمع مرة أخرى براين تود سي إن إن واشنطن
، الشعب الأمريكي
متحد والعالم موحد ونقف مع
شعب أوكرانيا ولن نسمح
للأباطرة المستبدين والأباطرة المحتملين بإملاء
اتجاه الديمقراطيات العالمية في
الصعود  لمقابلة هذه
اللحظة
حشد العالم إلى جانب السلام
وجانب الأمن ،
فإننا نظهر قوتنا
ولن نتعثر ،
بارك الله فيكم جميعًا ، بارك الله في أوكرانيا
وبارك الله قواتنا
، قال بيتك الأبيض أن
روسيا قد  استخدام الأسلحة الكيميائية أو
إنشاء عملية علم كاذب
لاستخدامها ما هو الدليل الذي رأيته يوضح
ذلك وهل سيكون لدى الولايات المتحدة رد عسكري
إذا شن بوتين هجومًا بالأسلحة الكيميائية ،
لن أتحدث
عن المعلومات الاستخبارية ولكن أه روسيا تريد
دفع ثمن باهظ لهذه
المواد الكيميائية
[موسيقى]
لك